petit
Brico bonjour et bienvenue dans
l'émission Les petits bricoleurs
aujourd'hui ça fait mon comment il fait
un press papier pour la fête des
papas alors donc pour faire le Pr N a
besoin un
galet la peinture blanc
acrylique fil de
fer une pince une serviette en papier
avec des motifs dessus
vernic avec un
pinceau alors donc nous commence par
peine le
galet en blanc
comme ça quand on met les motifs de la
serviette il voit mieux il ressort mieux
dessus plusieurs couches une couche la
sécher une deè couche sécher jusquà
bienine bien
jolie voilà donc les on passe une deè
cause une pe de TR couch g Gal est bien
joli est bien peine voilà ça donne donc
est comme ça donc maintenant ça colle le
papillon
dessus le plus gros là découpe le
papillon voilà le
papillon donc avant de coller il faut
enlève le petit papier blanc
derrière
le papier derrière ça on enlève enlève
ça pas besoin de ça on va coller ce
papillon donc on regarde où on veut
coller on positionne bien le
papillon et ensuite on va prendre le le
vernicle donc c'est un vernis qui colle
ça donne la brillance aussi en même
temps donc nous prend Le Vern
col un petit peu sur le galet comme
ça et n prend le papier
n mett dessus et nous repasse un peu le
vernicol
dessus comme
ça voilà donc après sur le bord peux
faire comme ça aussi sur le bord
arranger un peu
là faire un petit dentelle comme dirait
le CR un petit dentelle comme ça sur le
bord doncand a fini colle le papillon il
donne ça regarde comme c'est magnifique
si il veut écrire sur le galet il peut
écrire sur le galet bonne fête papa ou
le nom de le papa ou la date comme il
veut chacun est libre de faire à sa
manière il faudra laisser sécher un peu
hein donc on va laisser
sécher on va prendre les morceaux de fil
de
fer un morceau assez
long cette grandeur là la pince pour
couper
alors donc là on va faire le tour du
galet on va
mettre tout le tour comme
ça donc va
bien alors on tourne donc il tourne une
fois comme
ça faut reprendre la pince pour bien
tourner comme ça bien fait avec la
pince
pas trop fond parce que sinon va casser
le fil voilà donc là ça tient bien donc
maintenant on va arranger un peu en haut
là alors
donc toujours avec la pince on fait une
petite boucle arond comme
ça
donc après je en roule comme
voilà donner une forme comme
çaau de fer comme ça qu' veut ça aussi
pareil retourne ici le petit morceau de
fer voilà donc là pareil après tu
arrange comme tu veux comme ça
là
et là maintenant tu
prends un papier ou une photo là tu peux
mettre soit une photo soit fait la forme
d'un cœur pouvez mettre là bonne fête
papa ou la photo de l'enfant alors donc
pour faire un cœur donc on p un carré de
en triangle comme ça et on fait un
cœur
voilà donc là vous écrivez bonne fête
papa ou
voilà et voilà ce que ça donne vous
pouvez mettre la photo de l'enfant la
photo du papa vous écrivez là comme aut
il veux
Ie souhaite à toutes les papas bah une
bonne fête et à la prochaine émission au
revoiris
petit
bricoolleur